- Ha, this is the creepiest
thing I've ever seen in my life.
- How to make candidates
more likable, ugh.
- Maybe they could dress up as, like,
Disney characters.
They could do a few debates
as Disney princesses.
- Be chill, stop caring
about being the president.
That's how you become president.
- Oh hey, girl!
It's Hillary Clinton.
- Nobody's been elected
president without eyeballs.
- Don't look at me like that, Hillary.
- Oh, I think people think
she's a little fierce,
so what if we put a kitty?
- I back this candidate.
- Is that Richard Nixon?
- Who even is this?
- Chris Christie, right? Yeah!
- He yells at people a lot.
These will make Chris
Christie more cuddly.
- Everybody's got scandal,
I'm gonna wear it,
I'm gonna own this bridge thing.
- Oh, I wish I had a Santa hat.
Because, like, if Chris
Christie gave people toys,
I think that would help a lot.
So here is my revamped Chris Christie.
- Well, well, well, who do we have here?
- Pimp. (laughs)
- Oh, God, no!
- Oh, Jesus!
- This candidate is Donald Trump.
- So let's hide that hair,
that'll make you more likable.
Let's put some glue under here, too,
just like your normal hair every day.
- So, Donald Trump needs
some perspective in life.
I wanted him to be in someone else's skin.
Granted, no one has this skin,
but now he does, and now he's different,
he's an other, and he has to deal with it.
- Who is the messed-up kid
who put eyeballs on everyone?
It's terrifying, who did that?
I'm gonna find you.
- I think if I were to
give actual advice to them,
I would say just be more honest.
- You should be sincere, you should be
passionate about what you believe in.
- Kanye 2020, right?